hello again with a white suit so that
seems to be uh what he's going to do for
this world championship match dress in
the colors that he is playing with okay
the move has been taken back what's it
going to be
is that a king's pawn d4 i think that's
e4 oh that's e4 oh well all of our
predictions are
wrong with the opening unfortunately wow
it's a king spawn opening and
how will the pony actually react big
moment
it's e5 no sicilian okay so they're like
switching the colors because magnus with
black against diane it was e4 e5 so now
now we see magnus playing four with
white it's always uh nice to see new new
openings being played so this is so far
the same as in game three uh yeah until
this last move uh janna pogba she now
has just played copycats and it's the
petrov defense i wonder how many people
would have guessed this because uh
iannapolly actually not known for this
opening uh he played it a couple of
times i think in the candidates
tournament earlier this year but that
was really the first time we've seen it
from him
and it's not traditionally his style
either just to play kind of a drawish
kind of solid opening
and okay magnus is going to pawn up
temporarily
but white's knight having grabbed
opponent gets kicked back and the
pontiac will regain his pawn so this is
well-known stuff and arya and this is
this happened a lot right in the match
between castle and caruana in 2018. yeah
this is uh the petrov and it's known to
be like the most solid openings uh in
chess but but as
david said it's a bit surprising that
young plays it because
he it's not usually his style he plays
like he played like sicilian his whole
life he's known to be an aggressive
player but for for the match it's
probably a good strategy it's
interesting i was talking to anish like
two months ago and we were discussing
which opening ian will go for after e4
and i was thinking the sicilian but
anish actually predicted that jan will
go for the petrov
and i was surprised that he he said that
but he was actually actually right spot
on yeah anish guri
clearly uh yeah i can see the future so
uh meanwhile a couple more moves
both sides just occupying the center
with pawns bringing bishops out this is
still very very standard stuff and uh
okay i wonder who launched the first
surprise because i think magnus avoided
this exact position uh in his match
against caruana he was trying different
lines for petrov or against the petrov
as white okay both sides now just
castling their kings
still very traditional